as we Mark the start of Black History
Month the College Board is introducing a
first of its kind course on
African-American studies it's the first
for many reasons in part because high
school students for the first time will
combine history along with art and
culture in this course it's also become
controversial Florida's education
department under Governor Ron DeSantis
has already announced the chorus will
not be allowed in Florida high schools
at least based on the pilot even though
the actual
has not been released the framework for
the class has not been available until
now first on CBS morning's College Board
CEO David Coleman and AP
African-American studies director and
program manager Brandi Waters joined us
to unveil what's actually in this course
has got everybody talking so Brandi I
want to go to you first as the creator
of this course what's in it what can
students expect this course is so
exciting it's an amazing course it's one
where students have the opportunity to
delve into the depths of
African-American experiences they see
the diversity of these communities and
the broader connections between the U.S
and the African diaspora it's a course
that allows students as you mentioned to
explore resources in the Arts and the
Sciences in politics and really come
away understanding their current
situation much more deeply how much did
it change from the pilot to what's being
revealed today so we were constantly
iterating we put out a number of
different sources for the first pilot
and immediately started talking with
students and teachers where the course
was living and just ask them which
source are interesting which sources are
engaging which sources make your
creativity come alive and started
tweaking from there David what did you
think about the controversy especially
in Florida where people were criticizing
the course who really hadn't seen it and
didn't know anything about it
you know uh we at the College Board
don't really look to the statements of
politicians but we do look to the record
of History so when we revised the course
there are only two things we went to we
went to it brand new described which is
feedback from teachers and students as
well as 300 professors who have been
involved in building the course and we
went back to principals that have guided
AP for a long time and served us well
and what you'll find when you read it as
I hope you will is you'll find an
unflinching encounter with the facts and
evidence of African-American history and
culture that gives young people the
chance to think for themselves and it's
an African-American history American
history as well I think people sometimes
make the distinction don't you I
couldn't agree with you more you know we
all know today's the first day of Black
History Month yes and I know you know
that the great black educator Carter
Woodson is the one who inspired Black
History Month and he said in 1922 excuse
me 1922 just about 100 years before
today he said soon we'll be able to tell
our story and only then can we be
recognized as people but this was raises
the question and Brandi maybe you speak
to this if you know of course
African-American history is American
history why the separate course why the
need for it well what's really exciting
about this course is that it's not an
African-American history course it's an
African-American studies course so we're
giving students the opportunity to enter
this professional discipline that
normally they wouldn't access until
college but now they can get it in high
school and all students all students
students Brandi the phrase critical race
theory has become so politically charged
and it's almost used to denigrate some
in the Lexicon when you hear the phrase
and the way it's misused what do you
tell people who say oh it's critical
race Theory that's what it what do you
say to them well I think as a scholar
who's read many of these works the first
question I have to ask them is what they
mean by critical race Theory I'm sure
you've had this question before too
absolutely and I'll tell you just our
point of view in the advanced placement
program about a theories like this it's
not about picking this Theory or that no
AP course whether that's our course in
Japanese culture and language or Spanish
culture and language requires students
to study a specified Theory trains them
in an interpretation instead it immerses
them directly in the facts and evidence
and lets them think for themselves the
facts and evidence instead what they do
is they have a research project at the
end of the course where they get to pick
something and then they do compare what
they're learning about to other
interpretations what course yeah yeah
one of the criticisms was it it
significantly lacks educational value
again based on the pilot yeah basically
yeah what do you what do you both think
when you hear that I I got to tell you
working with Brandy over these past few
years has been a glory to me and and I
just want to give her a chance to
describe the so many surprises
everything is in this course the black
inventors and artists who have just
recently been seen the black and women
and men and gay Americans who are
pivotal in the Civil Rights Movement the
people of Faith from all backgrounds who
contributed so much the anti-slavery
cause and the role of faith in the black
community this course hides from nothing
it sees everything but Brandy what do
you think sure I think less than 30
seconds Brandy that critique has been
around for a while but I know in my life
this field has changed the way that I
think about my communities how I relate
to others and students will have that
same experience can adults take the
class I'm thinking this sounds good
probably by the textbook
yeah can adults take the class I'm
serious they should follow along with
students okay yeah okay we're hearing
about families who are doing the
readings at their dinner table this is
deep work yes hardwall thank you Bravo
congrats we're better for listening